- [Narrator] This is the eastern bongo.
These beautiful chestnut
and white-striped creatures
can only be found in four
isolated regions of Kenya.
(mysterious music)
Eastern bongos are fairly large in size
and can weigh anywhere
from 500 to 900 pounds,
and their horns can be
as long as 40 inches.
In fact, their horns are as wide
as the widest part of their body.
Despite their large size,
eastern bongos are rather timid creatures.
They are herbivores.
They tend to eat and are most active
during twilight and dusk
as the darkness helps them
to hide from predators.
There is estimated to be about
100 bongos left in the wild,
putting them well below the
critically endangered threshold.
Their biggest threats are hunting
and the destruction of their habitat.
In an effort to protect the eastern bongo,
various parts of their
native habitat in Kenya
have been designated as shelters for them,
allowing the eastern bongo to
move about freely and safely
without fear of poachers.
This is the eastern bongo.
(bright music)